and what did you know the composite of
your audience member who they were after
you made vomit she said you want amazing
shirts ya know I I knew who my audience
was while I was making vomit you know
and the t-shirts were total brain fart
you know and it's like how you can get
caught up into doing what you want to do
and not you know and you know and still
not pay attention you know and so
like that's going to happen with every
project didn't you just got to cut
yourself some slack and you know move on
and what I cost myself you know I
probably still have six inch dollars
worth of t-shirt inventory that i
haven't sold you know because of that
okay so that's six hundred bucks you
know I've made there's many worse
mistakes to make than a
six-hundred-dollar t-shirt manufacturing
mistake so you know yes it was a mistake
but I learned from it and you know
wasn't that costly you know so um so
anyway did that answer your question or
what but just so you said all along you
knew who you were making this film for
you knew who pretty much I mean yeah you
know it was pretty clear who our
audience was going to be and it pretty
much has been that audience the one
thing that we I didn't realize actually
about my audience is how much they would
resist paying for the content you know
ed and you know like I just found vomit
up on youtube in its entirety with a
hundred thousand views recently that I
have no connection to and I could take
it down right but it's like it's
100,000 views why am I going to take it
down that's actually there's some value
in that for me now if there was a method
which they're starting to be what I
would like is to be able to call youtube
and say look I don't want to take this
down but I want the ad revenue to funnel
to me now not to this guy that's the
difference you know I don't want to do
DC mi takedowns I want to just be able
to call youtube it's a channel the
revenue to me so I have
to them about that there's a company
that's doing that for the studios but
they're not it doesn't scale for
independence unfortunately so hopefully
within five years it will be scale ill
scale for independence but anyway that's
sidetracking you know that was the one
thing about my audience yeah is that how
and I should have been aware of that I
should have known like look these are
people who you know blink don't blink
about committing you know breaking rules
let's put it that way so are they really
going to engage with my content in the
way that I want them to which is going
to monetize it and chances are no so you
know but that's you know it's just a
matter of like you know we were what I
have to learn from that is to then think
about and that's something I have to
talk to my aggregator about is to think
about how i can put up vomit for free
and still monetize it you know for Obama
to and even as we re release bomb at one
how I can put it up into various forms
for free and still monetize it so that
would be pushing Netflix you know over
other platforms pushing hulu over other
platforms probably pushing youtube /
other platforms and having it on YouTube
for free simultaneously just because
it's going to happen anyway so I might
as well be the one doing it
you